the World Health Organization warns
there's no evidence that people who
people who have recovered rather from
the corona virus are protected from a
second infection
South Korea's CDC says that 268 patients
have retested positive after it was
thought they had recovered so now that's
raising some very troubling questions
about whether this virus can be
reactivated senior medical correspondent
that's dr. Tara Narula shows us why the
answer could be critically important it
just felt like time somebody was like
stabbing me with Colorado nurse
practitioner Lisa Merck has been
documenting her coronavirus journey
since she first tested positive in March
as a healthcare worker Merck gets repeat
tests so she knows when she can safely
return to work on day 21 of isolation
she got good news just seven days later
she got a retest and was shocked at the
results
Merck was once again positive for kovat
19 that's really confusing it's very
frustrating do you feel like you got
infected twice with coronavirus or do
you feel like that test that came back
negative was a false negative I feel
like the test that came back was a false
negative I mean there's no way to tell
viral PCR tests based on nose and throat
swabs like these are reliable about 60
to 90 percent of the time depending on
the test can people get coded twice so I
don't think we know the answer yeah dr.
Stanley Pearlman a professor at the
University of Iowa has been studying
corona viruses like stars and MERS for
nearly 40 years 50 percent of people are
so who had a SARS infection actually
still have antibodies now which is 17
years later and so that would tell you
maybe most of them are protected against
SARS again for MERS the amount of
antibody seams that decline fairly
rapidly if you have mild disease you
have severe disease the last much longer
just like with MERS dr. Pearlman
believes more severe Kovan 19 symptoms
may mean longer lasting immunity
so this disease we think that you will
be protected at least for some amount of
time especially if you had pneumonia if
you have only the upper airway infection
you may get infected again Perlman says
the good news is that kovat 19 is not
mutating quickly so this means that
making a vaccine is more feasible
because the virus isn't changing what do
you make of the Korean CDC saying that
corona virus may in fact be reactivating
in people who they initially thought
were cured yeah the question is whether
there really is reactivation or it's low
level infection that was not detected
for a period of time and I was detected
Martin Hirsch of Massachusetts General
Hospital agrees he says genetics and
several other factors affect immune
response younger people healthy people
without any underlying conditions are
the most likely to develop prolonged
antibodies with kovin 19 the World
Health Organization says we need more
evidence about how effective the
antibodies are and how long immunity
will last when we're talking about this
idea of potentially getting infected for
a second time what timeframe would sound
reasonable to you for that to make sense
I think those people who test positive
and negative and then positive within a
few days or a few weeks are almost
certainly not reinfected I think if you
go beyond that a few months a few years
then you can start talking about a
reinfection Lisa's right Terra Terra
joins us now Lisa's right when she says
it is
how could it be that you can have the
antibodies and not be immune to the
corona virus it's definitely confusing
and a lot of people equate the two terms
but antibody is not synonymous with
immunity antibody just tells you that
you've been infected before immunity is
really this more complex idea it's a
continuum and it depends on several
things it depends on the number of
antibodies you produce the type of
antibodies you produce so there are
neutralizing antibodies those are the
ones we know that really work most
effectively and neutralizing the virus
you want more of those it also depends
on other parts of the immune system we
have t-cells that work with the cells
that make the antibodies that help and
then we have memory cells as well that
produce antibody down the road when you
see the virus again we are all still
learning so much Thank You Terra very
much